space took this bureaucratic turn as a
result of History you know World War II
and the Cold War and in space become a
list point of national pride and so you
had to make rockets that wouldn't fail
because you'd be embarrassed for your
whole country so this became the stuff
of government projects billions upon
billions of dollars things went great
for a while and then it gets cemented
and you can't take a risk anymore SpaceX
is now running laps around the entire
world at this point in terms of launches
rocket families it's now the biggest
satellite manufacturer of the world has
ever seen and so they're the only ones
that have really succeeded but man
they've succeeded on such a level that I
don't think the world has really ever
seen before